[Music]
what's going on world for first we feast
I'm Sean Evans comin at you with a very
special report from foggy London town
we're finally here to meet the chicken
connoisseur well any cool
we're here at chicken town we're gonna
eat some lunch
we're gonna catch up but first trip
check the Nike will good lever I think
is a collab on ID I have a custom do
raise as well crap connoisseur a max
one's nice leva Polly dug deep in the
closet haven't worn these shoes in three
or four years it's the camo Air Force
Ones
[Music]
let's go can I get the junior special in
the wings and fries combo and then I
want to try the SAS burger I'll just go
for a junior special only got two pounds
do you ever think about why or how the
chicken connoisseur videos have become
so popular do you ever really think
about it again
it came with mayo and I offer burger
sauce is this is this company policy to
disregard what a man says I'm reviewing
stuff that people can go and taste for
themselves a place is a pretty
accessible so quite cheap and for the
most part it should be nice you think
that if you're doing chicken reviews and
the United States that they'd be as
popular if that was anywhere else I
don't think it would work as well just
because London has kind of relate to the
culture of blowing chicken shops and
stuff we've all kind of been raised
around chicken shop chicken shops have
always been there for us so like there's
a lot of things involved in it like it's
all kind of from like the grime culture
anything and everything we would usually
go chicken shop we were always at a
chicken shop even if we weren't
necessarily hungry sometimes like we
might just have a spare pound and we're
bored and we'll go ticket shop we'll get
some wings we'll chill and and - the
price point is something that I was kind
of shocked to see you know I look at all
of these menus I see a pound two pounds
three pounds for like these whole meals
I'm not sure how it is that cheap but
I'm glad it is because yeah just save a
lot of money $1.99 and I did not get my
one key change but allow it
[Music]
so let's not waste any time let's just
dive in here okay we start with the
fries so here's my whole thing with
fries like this I'll show you the math
I'll tell you what I'm thinking now with
a fry like this you always want it to
have dense potato in there you don't
want it to be like an empty sleeping bag
that's one of these miss now watch see
that that's dense because you can kind
of squeeze the toothpaste out and that's
what I'm looking for into fry like this
well show me your math shipping kind of
store you just make it to your own taste
and you pour it on
that's a blizzard for me it's all flavor
really just flavor and texture and I do
take into account the fact that is a
full like real potato so this is
probably like my first time having these
types of chips what do you think need
some sauce the breading is kind of
hollow and there's not much flavor to it
but it's well cooked I guess so we have
chicken here that's steamed and then
it's marinated in buttermilk and then
it's flash-fried and then you have a
unique house spice blend on top of this
how is it
brav
I have been living on these like bad
hotel breakfasts all week long here's my
mark against London I get a fruit salad
yeah it is a stack of grapefruit and
like random melon you know what I mean
every time I get the fruit I'm like like
I can't even finish it and then I'm like
eating a croissant and then I got like
two coffees and then I gotta shoot all
day you know I'm saying chicken kind of
short but this is what makes it all
worth it
when I can get a toasted bun when I can
get a chicken sandwich when I can bite
right through that this is heaven on
earth to me wing than that tell me the
best thing about the low market everyday
food shop and then the worst thing about
the low market everyday food shop I do
like the vibe in there but that's kind
of half the problem because they don't
really accommodate for people to come
there and eat like a another restaurant
like right because sometimes even with
you like you'll have to go eat on the
curb
you know like sitting right on the
street with like people walking by while
you're just like eating fries next to a
garbage can like they just rub on
haven't you get your stuff and then
leave ASAP so that you're not a
liability yeah exactly
[Music]
chicken connoisseur it was a crash
course I learned so much I appreciate
you showing me around and we have to do
it again man stay in the life
three-two-one